how are you michael hi christine fine
thanks yourself i'm doing well thank you
for talking to me about this i'm having
fun watching all of the shenanigans that
everyone is getting up to on it oh yeah
lots of shenanigans for sure yeah when
the opportunity to play one of these
nine perfect strangers came your way
what got you most excited and interested
in this project well first of all i had
worked with jonathan jonathan levine
before
on the night before and i had really
enjoyed the experience of working with
him
and
he called me himself and asked me if i
would do it and
i said well let me look at some of the
scripts and um
uh when i when i started to see what it
was about and what he was asking me to
do i i thought wow that's uh
that's pretty uh intense uh that's a big
responsibility
because uh
there are a lot of people that have
actually gone through what the marconi's
go through in the show
which is the the family that i'm a
member of in the show so uh i thought
that i
i thought it was very important to to
get it right and i i thought that i was
up for the challenge so
yeah this is a guy that goes into this
with his family with his wife and and
daughter
what was it like to have that little
family unit to go through this with you
aren't one of the strangers who's there
by themselves
right
yeah i always said that was kind of
interesting it's
you know it's not really not perfect
strangers i mean three of us are related
but
it just goes to show
uh in the in
at the end of the day that you can still
be a stranger even to someone in your
own family which i do feel like at the
beginning anyway
uh we we are kind of strangers to one
another um
we're certainly strange to one another
i'm certainly strange to them they don't
they can't understand what i'm about at
all so
i guess it does make sense yeah
how's the experience of doing the whole
waterfall scene what was it like to be
over the waterfall and deciding whether
or not to jump
wow that was
what a day that was that was crazy i
mean you know
um
obviously they they they go out of their
way to make sure that everything's uh
incredibly safe uh using um
various uh
wires and harnesses and whatnot
uh but nevertheless uh standing on the
edge of a waterfall is uh
is pretty trippy um
and
you know we'd be out there for a few
minutes and we'd be fine and then all of
a sudden one of us would start getting a
little vertigo and
and you know
uh freaking out a little bit and then we
need a little break
come back uh from the edge um so
yeah it's uh
that's one of the great things about
what i do i mean i don't i don't think i
have ever done
that otherwise if uh if i didn't have to
do it in a scene so
i'll never forget it that's for sure
to contrast that the potato sack race
looked like it was a lot of fun what was
it like to shoot that how long did you
have to shoot that for
oh yeah that was
that was just uh
like
half a day
we actually did something else that day
too so it wasn't even the whole day
but uh
it was a lot of fun
although it's uh it is
a lot of exercise it's oddly uh
well particularly because you know when
you when you're doing a potato sack race
in real life you don't
you don't do it over and over and over
and over again so
we you know because there's a lot of
coverage on that scene we had to
obviously do it more than once so
uh yeah we all got our exercise that day
that's for sure
if you're gonna get screwed around with
by anyone it seems like nicole kidman is
a good choice to have do that to you
what did you most enjoy about exploring
the dynamic between your characters and
having someone like her as a steam
partner because she really has a complex
dynamic going with pretty much everybody
on the show
she does and she pulls it off so
beautifully you know as i i remember
thinking
um
that such those are such big shoes to
fill you know the person that's offering
wellness to all these different people
with all these different problems and
and as much as people want that they
want to feel better or well or whatnot
they're also
i think uh predisposed to be very
cynical and skeptical about it
so it's like you know well
what are you gonna tell me that i don't
know already or what secret do you have
that's gonna make me
feel like a million bucks and that's
that's a lot of pressure but um
i mean nicole just inherently possesses
this
you know ethereal kind of
magical
quality that um
you know the the first day she came on
the set just immediately
uh
her
her charisma just took over and uh
it was very easy to be
succumbed to succumb to it to be seduced
by it yeah
you also did bullet train which is set
to come out next year how did you find
the experience of working with
david leach and having a director on an
action film that comes from such a heavy
stunt background does that change things
at all
you know i've done lots of stunt uh
stuff over the years so i'm i'm familiar
with that uh
that aspect of things um but david is uh
he's a very uh uh smart person and he's
as interested in uh
in character as anything else um
and i mean the funnest parts of of
working on bullet train were
uh for me anyway was was the scene work
you know i mean the
the the fighting is is going to be you
know
phenomenal don't get me wrong but uh
uh
i signed on because i really just
enjoyed
the the script so um
but i'm very very curious to see it i
i'm it's it's i'm impatient to see it
i guess it's not coming out until april
next year so
yeah it was a lot of fun
who do you play in that
who know i play yeah
i don't know if i'm even allowed to say
why i play ball
i don't want to get in trouble yeah no i
don't want you to get in trouble well
what what was your reaction to learning
the ending of nine perfect strangers and
learning where the story and your
character would end up how did you feel
about that
i mean i i don't want to spoil anything
but i i i was
i was pretty satisfied with it
truth be told i
felt like a pretty
pretty uh
dense and uh
i don't know satisfying journey you know
i
felt like mission accomplished
that's always a good feeling to have
when you do a project
yeah yeah
well thank you i appreciate you talking
to me about it i i
i'm tremendously enjoying it so thank
you
thanks christina thank you